mike is with us in Akron hey Mike
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up all right so we my wife and I
have spent many years and we got
ourselves out of that ATS out of dad
everything except the house good and you
know we struggle we have four kids we
have one more on the way
I run a business she's at home we had
pinned a lot of hopes on selling our
house and we had it listed we've lost
two contracts because of a structural
issue that came up so basically a lot of
the the things we are planning on like a
down payment for another house in a new
state we've recently moved so we're
renting right now we have the house back
in Akron so the down payment and also a
new minivan we're going to come from
this the proceeds of this house sale but
it looks like we're not going to get
those proceeds now so I'm torn between
between paying for all the structural
work to be done with which I probably
have to borrow on or just drastically
dropping the price of the house and
walking away with nothing mmm and after
all these years of struggling it's
difficult to what is your whole eighth
note what's your household income sixty
okay no sorry sorry
72 okay and you're not able to make
progress with that well we're able to
make progress but I spent a good bit of
that progress in cash to fix up this
house a lot more the cosmetic things
okay and what is the various the costs
to fix the structural issue probably
going to be about 15,000 okay what's
wrong with it there's a it means a
couple of the walls in the basement are
bowing mm-hmm and there's a beam someone
took out a wall a long time ago there's
a little bit of a sag in a beam mm-hmm
have you got well that's a post that's
not a rock that's not rockets on it sir
have you gotten bids yep
how many up one so far yeah okay you
need three I'm sort of you need to rate
minimum mm-hmm some can find out what's
really going on here and you need to
talk to the people giving the bids and
go look I don't want to do anything
wrong and I don't want to mislead a
buyer but on the other hand I have no
desire to completely rebuild this house
so your child can go to college right
this is you talking to the contractor so
the one that uses the most common sense
with a legitimate with integrity fix to
this is the one that's going to get the
job and so how much money do you have
saved we have like ten well about eight
thousand right now okay because we use a
lot of our say our emergency fund
savings our big emergency fund savings
that do this work on the house yeah okay
and so what is the house worth if it
were fixed up and it sold properly well
we just had we just lost the contract
for 132 okay and what would it sell for
if you don't do the fix my realtor
things would be probably I'd probably
have to sell it for 100 or 95 something
like that okay and so we're talking
about a thirty seven thousand dollar
loss in return for a fifteen thousand
dollar fix I think I'm doing the fix but
I'm not gonna borrow the money I mean
you get your butt to work and you guys
cut down to nothing and we clean out the
emergency fund we find somebody to fix
the thing for ten or twelve thousand we
find that other four thousand to put
with the eight you got and you get the
thing fixed and you fix it with cash and
you get it out of your life
but I think I'm fixing it I'm not
thinking this is fifteen thousand I
think you're gonna get some other bids
and you're gonna find a way to work
around this that's what we do when we're
paying cash when we borrow money we
close our eyes and point and push the
red button and then everything explodes
and then we wish it worked out right but
it doesn't so you fight your way through
this dude you're almost there hey guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you enjoyed that
video from the Dave Ramsey show if you
want to watch another great video check
out my video
three things you should consider rinsing
right over here or click the link in the
description below